>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, chúng tôi phải giới thiệu một thế giới tính năng hoàn toàn mới
của JavaScript.
Đây là những tính năng xảy ra bên ngoài chính công cụ JavaScript của chúng tôi.
Đây là các tính năng của trình duyệt web.
JavaScript là một tính năng nhỏ của trình duyệt web rộng hơn.
Trình duyệt web có đầy đủ các tính năng.
Ký túc xá, đó là mô hình của chúng tôi
trang web mà JavaScript có thể tương tác với để thay đổi nội dung trên trang web.
Đó là một loại đại diện của những thứ trên trang của chúng tôi
JavaScript có thể viết mã để tương tác với thay đổi trang web của chúng tôi.
Đó là một tính năng bên ngoài JavaScript.
Bảng điều khiển là một tính năng khác của trình duyệt web, một tính năng bên ngoài JavaScript.
Bộ nhớ cục bộ của chúng tôi, cơ sở dữ liệu đó trong trình duyệt.
Khả năng nói chuyện với Internet, khả năng XHR,
tất cả những điều này không phải là tính năng JavaScript.
Chúng được tìm thấy trên MDN.
Dưới dạng danh sách các tính năng của trình duyệt web được biết đến hoặc có thể là nó, trong JavaScript là API của trình duyệt web.
Lý do họ biết đến điều đó trong JavaScript là chúng tôi sử dụng các nhãn cho
những tính năng đó từ bên trong JavaScript để kích thích,
để bắt đầu, một tính năng của trình duyệt web.
Và bất kỳ tính năng nào không có trong thời gian chạy của riêng tôi,
trong công cụ của riêng tôi là một cái gì đó giao diện với.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi gọi nó là Giao diện AP là một API, vì vậy chúng tôi tương tác bên ngoài
JavaScript. >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi phải giới thiệu những
để có cơ hội giải quyết câu hỏi hóc búa ba chiều này.
Cơ hội duy nhất mà chúng tôi có để giải quyết vấn đề này là các tính năng của trình duyệt web được giới thiệu hoặc
trong Node, chúng được gọi là chuỗi nền hoặc API trong Node.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi đi mọi người.
Từng dòng một, chúng ta sẽ đi qua vấn đề này.
Và giải pháp này tôi sẽ nói với bạn,
mọi thứ khác chỉ là một sự gia tăng của giải pháp này.
Tôi thích giải pháp này.
Nhưng các nhà thiết kế JavaScript nhận ra một số lỗi của giải pháp này.
Và giải pháp ba sẽ là giải pháp hoàn toàn mới của chúng tôi.
Và đó là phổ biến nhất.
Nhưng tôi vẫn nghĩ giải pháp cuối cùng của chúng ta, chúng ta sẽ thấy kết thúc của
tôi nghĩ ngày là giải pháp đặc biệt tốt đẹp.
Và tất cả các giải pháp này đều hoạt động bao gồm cả giải pháp hai nếu bạn hiểu cách chúng
làm việc dưới mui xe.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi bắt đầu.
Dòng một Michelle, chúng ta đang làm gì? >> Michelle: Chúng tôi đang tuyên bố
một hàm và bộ nhớ được gọi là print hello. >> Will Sentance: Xuất sắc.
Cảm ơn, Michelle.
Bạn có thể nói nó chậm hơn một chút trong khi tôi tiếp tục quét sạch màu trắng của tôi
bảng? >> Michelle: Chúng tôi đang xác định một chức năng trong
bộ nhớ được gọi là in xin chào. >> Will Sentance: In xin chào.
Tôi đang cố gắng giữ cho nét chữ của mình gọn gàng cho hậu thế.
Đi thôi.
Tốt hơn, tốt hơn.
Được rồi, xuất sắc.
Cảm ơn Michelle, xuất sắc.
Dòng tiếp theo, hãy nói chuyện chung với tôi.
Victor, chúng ta đang làm gì trong dòng tiếp theo của tôi?
Chúng ta đang gọi là gì? >> Victor: Tôi
nghĩ rằng chúng tôi đang gọi- >> Will Sentance: Đừng thử và
hãy thông minh về nó. >> Victor: Được rồi,
chúng ta đang nói về bối cảnh thực thi toàn cầu.
Để sử dụng a- >> Will Sentance: Được rồi,
ngừng cố gắng để trở nên thông minh.
Ai đó khác nói những thuật ngữ trừu tượng hơn.
Tốt lắm, Victor.
Chúng ta sẽ đến với nó trong giây lát.
Tôi chỉ muốn đầu tiên, Mike. >> Mike: Tôi nghĩ chúng ta đang
thực sự đang cố gắng in hàm của chúng tôi. >> Will Sentance: Được rồi, vậy
chúng ta chỉ cần trừu tượng hơn.
Chúng tôi đang gọi bộ hẹn giờ với những đối số nào,
Ben? >> Ben: Xin chào.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, toàn bộ bản in
xin chào định nghĩa hàm.
Hãy thực sự rõ ràng.
Khi tôi gọi một hàm, những ký hiệu nào cho tôi biết tôi đang gọi một sự kiện hàm?
>> Ben: Dấu ngoặc đơn.
>> Di chúc Cha, mẹ, cha;
cha mẹ.
Tôi đang gọi đã đặt thời gian chờ.
Tôi có thấy bất kỳ dấu hiệu nào ở cuối lời chào không?
Chắc chắn không phải,
Thay vào đó, tôi chuyển toàn bộ định nghĩa hàm vào thời gian chờ đã đặt.
Ai biết điều đó có nghĩa là gì? >> Nhiều: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Và đối số thứ hai
1.000 đại diện cho số mili giây
sau đó tôi muốn hàm print hello này được gọi, được gọi.
Vì vậy, nó sẽ được gọi tự động, có lẽ nằm ngoài tầm kiểm soát của tôi, phải không?
Ở đâu đó bên trong Đặt thời gian ra ngoài, sai, nhưng chúng ta hãy tưởng tượng đó là trường hợp.
Hãy tưởng tượng đó là trường hợp bằng cách nào đó, khi tôi đặt parens lên, hàm
gọi, Brian, tôi tạo cái gì, một cái mới? >> Brian: Bối cảnh thực thi.
>> Will Sentance: Bối cảnh thực thi,
mọi thứ cho thấy tôi sẽ,
chúng ta hãy xem điều gì sẽ xảy ra nếu đúng như vậy.
Bối cảnh thực thi mới, nó là Into it I go
và sau đó cộng với 1000 mili giây.
Nó sẽ ở trên ngăn xếp mát mẻ trong 1000 mili giây.
Chúng tôi sẽ ở bên trong này và bạn đã có ngữ cảnh thực thi.
Tại thời điểm đó, tôi sẽ, tốt, thời gian chờ đặt JavaScript sẽ yêu cầu
tôi, hãy in lời chào và chúng tôi sẽ trở lại.
Vào khoảng 1.001 mili giây và chạm vào dòng nào,
Michelle? >> Michelle: Bộ
hết giờ. >> Will Sentance: Nichole.
>> Michelle: Nhật ký bảng điều khiển.
>> Will Sentance: Nhật ký giao diện điều khiển,
tôi trước.
Được rồi, 1.001 mili giây sau.
Tôi đã tiếp tục chuỗi đồng bộ JavaScript của mình, một nghìn một [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC].
Điều này có vẻ khả thi,
như cách đặt thời gian chờ hoạt động? >> Michelle: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Đây sẽ là
tai hại.
Đây hoàn toàn không phải là những gì đã đặt thời gian chờ.
Trên thực tế, đặt thời gian chờ, không làm gì cả.
Đây là một điều nhỏ trong Javascript, nhưng
trên thực tế, chẳng có gì quan tâm đến JavaScript cả.
Thay vào đó, nó là một chức năng mặt tiền.
Mặt tiền cho chức năng xảy ra bên ngoài JavaScript.
Ở đâu?
Ở nơi nào? >> Nhiều: Trình duyệt.
>> Will Sentance: Trình duyệt web.
JavaScript không có bộ đếm thời gian. >> Will Sentance: JavaScript
không phải là bộ hẹn giờ đặt thời gian chờ đang sử dụng.
Chúng tôi phải giới thiệu một phần hoàn toàn mới cho nền tảng ứng dụng mô hình của chúng tôi, để
hiểu thời gian chạy của JavaScript.
Nó thậm chí không có trong JavaScript, >> Will Sentance: Trình duyệt web,
chúng ta hãy thử và giữ cho điều này ngăn nắp các tính năng của Trình duyệt web,
đây rồi, khoảnh khắc tự hào nhất của tôi, nó đây.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, Ben nhìn lên.
Đó là một minh họa đẹp. >> Nhiều: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Nó không tốt bằng tôi
nghĩ rằng nó thực sự là.
Tôi thất vọng vì điều đó.
Hãy để tôi thử lại lần nữa.
Tôi đã thực hành điều đó quá lâu.
Điều duy nhất tôi chuẩn bị.
Đi thôi.
Lần này quá nhỏ.
[LAUGH] Lần này tôi thấy nó quá nhỏ.
Bây giờ chúng ta hãy nhìn vào.
Được rồi, ở đây chúng ta đi thẳng.
Và bạn đã có phở cho thời gian này. >> Ben: Tôi
như Firefox. >> Will Sentance: Cảm ơn anh bạn,
đẹp. >> Nhiều: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Tôi thậm chí không biết những gì
trông như thế nào.
Nó có quá nhiều bit cho nó.
Và tôi cũng chống lại mã nguồn mở.
Không không. >> Nhiều: [LAUGH]
>> Will Sentance: Đó là một trò đùa.
Đó là một trò đùa.
Đó là một trò đùa, fan hâm mộ lớn.
Người hâm mộ lớn của Firefox.
Kể từ năm 2010, fan hâm mộ lớn.
Tất cả các tính năng trình duyệt web đúng, tốt.
Đặt hẹn giờ sẽ không làm gì trong JavaScript.
Thay vào đó, nó sẽ tạo thành một trang web
tính năng trình duyệt, nhưng cái nào?
Có ai biết những gì các tính năng được gọi là? >> Michelle: Một tác phẩm
nhóm? >> Ben: Hẹn giờ.
>> Will Sentance: Timer, Ben xuất sắc.
Bạn có năng khiếu.
Đây rồi, hẹn giờ.
Và chúng tôi sẽ lấy thông tin chúng tôi cần, đây là một chức năng mà chúng tôi muốn
đã gọi, tham chiếu đến vị trí trong bộ nhớ hàm của JavaScript, chúng tôi
sau đó muốn gọi và thuộc tính quan trọng là nghìn phần nghìn giây.
Và xuống trong trình duyệt web, xuống trong trình duyệt web, chúng ta sẽ quay lên
bộ đếm thời gian với 1.000 mili giây là tài sản của chúng tôi.
Và sau đó chúng ta sẽ có một loại điều kiện.
Nó đã hoàn thành chưa?
Ben, nó đã hoàn thành chưa? >> Ben: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Chắc chắn là không, chính xác.
Ở 1 phần nghìn giây, nó chắc chắn không hoàn thành.
Và sau đó khi hoàn thành, Ben,
chúng ta muốn kêu gọi điều gì? >> Ben: In
xin chào. >> Will Sentance: In chính xác lời chào trên
hoàn thành, khi hoàn thành, chúng tôi sẽ
muốn gọi >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi
chúng tôi sẽ muốn gọi chúng tôi sẽ chạy in.
Xin chào, chức năng.
Được rồi, công việc đặt thời gian chờ đã xong.
Đó chỉ là công việc đáng quan tâm là công việc mà nó thực hiện bên ngoài JavaScript.
Về mặt kỹ thuật trong JavaScript, nó trả về một giá trị đại diện cho bộ đếm thời gian, được rồi, tốt thôi.
Nhưng nó không có gì quan tâm đến JavaScript.
Công việc duy nhất của nó là trong trình duyệt Web quay công việc này.
Có nghĩa là, chúng ta có thể tiếp tục từ dòng này,
dòng này cho đến khi chúng tôi hoàn thành công việc của nó, bằng JavaScript, không có gì cả.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi chuyển thẳng đến Alec.
Dòng mã tiếp theo của chúng tôi là gì ở khoảng hai mili giây mà công cụ JavaScript,
chúng tôi vừa mới bắt đầu,
JavaScript engine sẽ thực thi? >> Alec: Trước tiên tôi sẽ đăng nhập vào
Bàn điều khiển. >> Di chúc: Chính xác,
đăng nhập cho tôi đầu tiên, đẹp.
Tôi đầu tiên là ở đó.
Và hãy nhìn xem, mọi người, chúng ta đang rất rất gần với hạnh phúc.
Chúng tôi đã xoay sở, chúng tôi đã bắt đầu một nhiệm vụ mất nhiều thời gian,
ở đây mặc dù chỉ là một bộ đếm thời gian có chức năng.
Bạn muốn gọi nó là kết thúc của nó, không phải là nhiệm vụ thú vị nhất nhưng
đó là một nhiệm vụ mất nhiều thời gian và chúng tôi đã tiếp tục đi thẳng.
Đó, tăng tốc, đó không phải là một phần bổ sung mới tốt cho sơ đồ của tôi.
Chúng tôi tiếp tục đi thẳng vào
trong công việc đồng bộ của chúng tôi lúc thực thi để thêm nhật ký bảng điều khiển.
Nhìn kìa.
Điều này rất, rất tốt.
Đây là phần đầu tiên.
Nhưng bây giờ chúng ta sẽ gặp phải vấn đề, về cơ bản nó sẽ
vấn đề của chúng tôi đang diễn ra, đó là, bây giờ chúng tôi có chức năng.
Điều đó hy vọng sẽ trở lại và được chạy, bằng cách nào?
Đồng bộ hóa JavaScript, mã đồng bộ JavaScript, giống như mã thông thường,
những thứ từ trên xuống dưới, từng dòng một, đã hoàn thành ngay bây giờ.
Nhưng vì tôi gọi ngăn xếp, tôi nên đánh dấu ngăn xếp cuộc gọi, xin lỗi.
Chỉ cần đảm bảo rằng cuộc gọi của chúng tôi sắp xếp.
Mã đồng bộ JavaScript được thực hiện ngay bây giờ.
Đây rồi.
Nhưng ở phía sau, một thế giới vạn vật đang diễn ra.
Bộ đếm thời gian nhỏ của chúng tôi, nó đang nhấp nháy, khi nó trôi qua.
Và ở khoảng 1001 mili giây, điều gì sẽ xảy ra?
Brian. >> Brian: Nó thực hiện in
xin chào. >> Di chúc: Đúng,
nó có hoàn thành ở 1000 mili giây không?
Bộ hẹn giờ của chúng ta có hoàn thành sau 1000 không
mili giây? >> Brian: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Đã hoàn thành và như vậy
chúng tôi có thể gọi in xin chào.
Nó có nghĩa là gì về mặt người gọi của tôi, Brian,
để nói rằng tôi thực hiện cuộc gọi in xin chào? >> Brian: Nó thêm nó vào một hàng đợi?
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi sẽ đến
đến điều đó trong một giây.
Nó có nghĩa là gì, nó cho biết ngăn xếp cuộc gọi của tôi? >> Brian: Nó
thêm in hello vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi. >> Will Sentance: Ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Tuyệt vời, Brian, cảm ơn anh bạn.
Nó thêm nó vào ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Điều đó có nghĩa là, điều đã
xảy ra bên ngoài trình duyệt web sẽ gửi một tin nhắn để nói.
In chức năng hello, lấy lại nó trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi.
Nó đã sẵn sàng để được thực thi trở lại trong JavaScript với tốc độ khoảng 1.001 mili giây.
Vì vậy, nó đây, nhìn vào đó.
Với 1,001 mili giây, chúng tôi nhận được Mã JavaScript của mình.
Hàm JavaScript của chúng tôi, hàm mà chúng tôi đã hoãn lại, được phép quay trở lại.
Nó gọi print hello, bản ghi console nào hello.
Và đây là một kết cục đẹp.
Đây là nó.
Ba mục tiêu của chúng tôi là thực hiện các nhiệm vụ mất nhiều thời gian
như trì hoãn một chức năng với bộ đếm thời gian.
Tiếp tục chạy mã Java Script của chúng tôi trong thời gian chờ đợi.
Rất tiếc, không, sai cách.
Tiếp tục chạy mã JavaScript của chúng tôi trong thời gian chờ đợi.
Mã bảng điều khiển, lần đầu tiên chúng tôi tiếp tục, ngay sau đó.
Chúng tôi thiết lập một nhiệm vụ, đặt ra thời gian, sẽ mất nhiều thời gian.
Chúng tôi thiết lập các nhiệm vụ dài hạn và chúng tôi sẽ tiếp tục ngay lập tức trong 2 phần nghìn giây sau đó
và khi nhiệm vụ chậm của chúng ta, tức là bộ đếm ngược này trên đồng hồ, hoàn thành.
Có thể chạy chức năng khi biết nhiệm vụ đã xong và dữ liệu đã sẵn sàng.
Không có dữ liệu để sẵn sàng ở đây.
Nhưng chúng ta sẽ thấy nó trông như thế nào trong giây lát.
Được rồi, không thích khái niệm này.
Tôi muốn nói thêm, có rất nhiều trường hợp cạnh tranh.
Những thứ bạn đi đến đâu, nhưng nếu điều đó xảy ra thì sao?
Nhưng nếu điều đó xảy ra thì sao?
Tôi muốn xem một số người thích trung bình để làm rõ nhưng nếu điều đó xảy ra thì sao?
Chúng tôi sẽ thấy trong giây lát khi bạn tương tác với một thế giới
bên ngoài công cụ JavaScript đồng bộ thuần túy này.
Bạn sẽ cần phải có một số quy tắc thực sự nghiêm ngặt để
khi công cụ JavaScript của chúng tôi cho phép chức năng khác biệt này trở lại.